California Congressman Eric's well well  who's in the race his approval rating  among Democrats is now over one percent  yeah yeah yeah he has broken the one  percent mark it's a mismatch it's a big  deal for the US wall well campaign which  is why his office wasted no time putting  this look out Cory Kristen G and Bernie  pros workouts of Alton lookout Julian  Castro look out Mike Ravel look out john  hickenlooper look out jay inslee look  out marianne williamson  look out Andrew Yang  it really has got many people that's the  funny part as you watch that you go yeah  it really is that many people running  right now that was there was a laughable  I know